how ubisoft's rabbits become intertwined
with nintendo's mushroom kingdom
featuring mario and friends is
unimportant
you might not like rabbid style toilet
humor going in but there's an admirable
and wholehearted commitment in mario
plus rabbids kingdom battle that
triumphs in creating a magical game
world that is undeniably delightful and
within it
houses a deep challenging turn-based
tactical combat system
the invasion of dim-witted rabbids
brings out the sillier side of the
mushroom kingdom
but with some interesting extra
weirdness the humor is self-aware a
little more twisted and
conscious of the real world but there's
so much charm packed into every cartoony
crevice of mario plus rabbits
everything from the vibrant world the
incredibly expressive enemy animations
right down to the choco worthy text
descriptions of every item makes it hard
not to find something that makes you
smile
but the most significant and strangest
disruption to the lives of the mario
brothers
aside from their new creepy rabid
doppelganger allies
are guns explosives and the imperative
to use them
if you're familiar with the pharaaxis
reboot of the x-com series you know what
to expect
turn-based conflicts take place on a
gridded isometric battlefield where
projectile weapons
cover and flanking other major focus
however
kingdom battle twists that design
heavily by introducing abilities and
options
that encourage a more aggressive style
of fighting as well as situational
urgencies to create a faster paced more
exciting ebb and flow to battle
unlike other tactical games combatants
are allowed to perform movement attacks
and special abilities in a single turn
and in any order this means using a
special ability doesn't stop you from
attacking during that same turn
movement doesn't need to be your first
consideration and you don't need to
finish performing all actions with one
character before using another
characters can also use their movement
face to attack you can select enemies to
dash into on the way to an endpoint
you can also reach out of range
locations by moving into allies and
letting them give you a boost
a technique called team jump a variety
of special abilities across characters
allows you to perform actions like buff
weapon damage
scare enemies away from a location an
attack on enemy movement
a parallel to x-com's overwatch ability
altogether the flexibility of how these
abilities can be used and how they can
be combined
as well as the reward incentive for
exceptional performance
means that you're pushed to perform
elaborate team maneuvers every turn and
take
big satisfying risks finding chances to
perform complex action strings and
having them pay off
is incredibly exhilarating and it's in
these moments where kingdom battle is
its best
but these moments don't happen all the
time and they're not always worth the
risk
reaching these highs is all the more
sweeter since the combat design
constantly keeps you on your toes
most cover is easily destroyed for
example and a firing position you set
yourself up in at the end of your last
turn
can just as easily be vaporized by the
first enemy to act
leaving you completely exposed to
follow-up attacks you could be hit by a
weapon with a super effect
potentially setting you on fire and
causing you to run out of cover like a
maniac
or block your ability to use certain
actions enemy rabbids can be highly
aggressive and cunning especially in
later stages
you could also be the cause of your own
demise since friendly fire is a factor
and the more powerful characters like
peach and rabid mario specialize in
large
area of effect damage on top of that
you'll have to keep in mind the long
cooldowns on secondary weapons and
special abilities
as well as your party's health status a
close victory could mean that using the
same team members in the next fight puts
you at a disadvantage
kingdom battles combat will have you
agonizing over every facet of
every possible action during each of
your turns thankfully agonizing is made
easy because of the game's clean combat
interface
and the clear communication of pertinent
information at a glance you can see the
kinds of actions your team can still
perform in a turn
full in half cover is clearly marked and
the visual design of arenas makes it
obvious what is and isn't destructible
kingdom battle uses a numerical
percentage system to denote the chance
for an attack to make contact
but the only numbers you'll see are 0 50
and 100 meaning you know what the hit
outcome of your attack will be with
confidence
or you'll be completely certain that the
outcome will be uncertain
there's a larger variety of chance when
it comes to status effects but at no
point will you throw your hands up in
frustration because peach missed a 90
probability shotgun blast to a rabid
stupid face
the game also gives you the option to
completely respect character skill
points on a whim
and restart a skirmish at any time both
without punishment
so you might find yourself in a losing
battle due to a completely terrible team
composition
but kingdom battle encourages you to
experiment with different strategies by
restarting the mission
re-surveying the battlefield swapping
out team members and completely changing
their abilities in order to suit the
situation
the result is that despite its
difficulty kingdom battle gives off a
feeling of encouragement
much more than it does frustration in
its mechanical design alone
outside of the battles you run mario and
friends through the silly light-hearted
world of a mushroom kingdom that's been
invaded by butt-scratching rabbits and
spending time in this world is the
perfect dose of positivity to keep you
going after a tough fight it's the
seamlessness of this world which gives
kingdom battle its greatest feeling of
character
and place exploration and puzzle
segments blend into battle arenas and a
small checkpoint banner is the only
distinction between stages
each world feels like a huge tangible
location as a result
mildly challenging puzzles occasionally
gate the way forward but never halt the
pace of events and mainstays of mario
platforming games like red rings and
coin rooms
provide the odd distraction every once
in a while mario plus rabbit's kingdom
battle
exudes offbeat optimism that never
dissolves it's a consistent delight no
matter how challenging the road becomes
because kingdom battle's unique
turn-based tactics system is in every
way a pleasure to engage with
coupled with the annoyingly infectious
allure of rabbids
and the always delightful world of the
mushroom kingdom mario plus rabbids
kingdom battle
is an implausibly engrossing formula
that is positively challenging
and endlessly charming
you